can we get
the original
on the dsps and the yellow album on the
test keys
okay those those are real expensive i
say that a lot my fans know because of
all the features in the sample clearance
no disrespect to that piff and right and
they're adding off man they have nothing
to do with it no but i'm just saying
that if i want to listen to i gotta go
down there i know or i gotta pull up to
youtube recently i just almost been like
you know [ __ ] it and let's just take our
shot and just run it see what happens
you can't see what happens
i know
so listen static selected always told me
this because he samples every all his
[ __ ] right i don't really want to air
his [ __ ] out like
but he's like hey bro [ __ ]
if if i get sued that means the record's
doing something yeah facts facts man but
with the again with the guest features
on there with the paperwork that they
tied to you could imagine that yeah
they're not going to let that feature
[ __ ] might be tough i got rig rocks
unless you just throw it off without it
without it having any of the features on
it like like the track list is just it
doesn't say their name on it oh yeah i
would have to i would have to if i went
that way but i have been in discussions
um we working on some maybe a little
anniversary or just some fly like a
relaunch for that one that would be
special man i definitely want to do that
before um sooner than later i will say
that i think about it a lot i've been in
discussions with
you know people that don't even have
nothing to do with me honestly but just
i just want to help that's in tune with
business and music and they're like yo
you know
look into this this and this but it's a
process you know it's like whiz finally
got cushioned orange juice on the dsl
exactly
you know i was exactly big crit got all
his old [ __ ] on the dsps it takes time
joey badass yeah and the era like that
you guys came up like they were mixtapes
but they weren't they were problems that
was like music it was just free music it
was great music for me i always made
wanted to make my music as albums i
always tried to keep that integrity but
it was free music back then you know so
i don't feel cheated i don't feel you
know better about none of that because
then that's how i made that music you
know i knew what i was doing going into
i came off the
era where they thought the music
business was done
that's real you feel what i'm saying
like people forget that when they ask
questions and they think like oh
they spotted like [ __ ] i don't think
about spotify when i make songs i'm
sorry you know what i'm saying like i
i'm i'm pa i was around before that like
i think about the fans i think about
what i want to say i think about great
music yeah because back then you guys
had to figure out how to monetize
everything else what the music cause you
were driving
you should die tomorrow i would not give
a [ __ ] you feel me like i would still do
my thing i would still figure it out i
would still make a way just like i did
before that's all they result of trying
to be in the music business like that it
doesn't really affect like my process
you know but at the end of the day i
want to get the flyers music possible to
the fans so that's where we have where i
have to deal with it